[Music]
well clark county is asking for your
input on the future of one october
memorial commissioners as well as
members of the one october memorial
committee
kicked off a process for accepting ideas
from the public on how to remember the
events of the 2017 shooting committee
members say it's been a priority to make
sure the communities affected by the
events feel included
survivors impacted family members people
in our community and those that don't
live in las vegas that felt touched by
this event being able to submit their
ideas is a huge um moment for this
committee right we want to be able to
get to the end of this process and have
everyone feel like they had a say and
they had a part in this
this incident affected 22 000 plus
people and we need the memorial to
reflect that
well it's an 18-month process and the
ways you can submit your ideas are by
going to the committee's website or
submitting through their mobile app and
of course we have more information on
our website 8newsnow.com